so with the writers strike over the Drew
Barrymore talk show will come back on
October 16th
but it'll be with new writers the show
had three uh wga Union writers
previously and they have all declined to
return now the show will still come back
as I said just with new writers and um
ultimately this is good if the writers
felt that they had the ability and the
standing to say no we felt disrespected
we're gonna go somewhere else that's
good thing and they should do that they
shouldn't be forced to go back to a job
where they felt that they were not
respected in their work I'm a little bit
surprised it happened to Barrymore
actually revise that I'm not surprised
but if it was going to happen to anyone
I kind of would have preferred it would
have happened to Bill Maher I mean I'm
not going to defend Barrymore she
screwed up but
more did say into a microphone that he
didn't think writers were entitled to
make a living doing their work so
there's a lot more contempt from him I
would have preferred to happen to him